first it was the anonymous New York
Times letter and now it's an undercover
video that an employee at the State
Department is seen hinting at a
resistance within the Trump
administration in part two of my
exclusive interview with Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo we get his reaction to
that and much more
watch Russia versus China there's a lot
of focus on Russia because of election
meddling threats of future election
meddling Ukraine relationship with
Europe and and trade and so forth as you
see things who's the bigger threat to
you at the US position in the world
economically strategically Russia or
China so I often get asked these
prioritization questions and it always
makes me a little bit queasy to answer
them they present such different
concerns to rank them I think sometimes
sends the wrong message to the American
people Russia has been aggressive Russia
has tried to meddle in our election
Russian under Vladimir Putin remains a
bully we need to push back and constrain
them where we can but longer term if
you're looking at the things that
threaten American livelihoods that put
America truly at risk of its continued
economic growth China prevents the four
presents the far greater threat to the
United States
there was concern from the foreign
policy elites mr. secretary
early on and expressed throughout this
administration that oh the Trump team
kind of bumbles through these events
they go out and promise a lot but then
the deliverables aren't there of course
they sight in North Korea North Korea is
not denuclearizing and the pace that
maybe we thought they would and so forth
but what's the real status with our
relationship with the Europe and our
relationship with with you know the
North Korean leadership given how things
have transpired well I'll start with
North Korea we have made steady I'll be
it slow progress but it's always we've
always known this was going to take some
time the South Koreans had a successful
engagement president moon with
and Kim just over the last 48 hours
where we made another step where we will
get verification of an element of North
Korea's program on the ground that's a
good thing what we're moving forward the
relationship between chairman Kim and
president Trump is good I talked to my
counterparts there with some frequency
it doesn't get reported I'm glad about
that
I'm glad we're able to keep that quiet
and so we're making the progress that we
need with respect to Europe look there
there was a reset that needed to take
place in the relationship we needed
Europe to step forward and begin to
share the burden of defense for the
European countries in a way that they
had not done under previous presidents
President Rome's trying to right that
ship we still have a fascinatingly
important relationship with Europe but
I'm confident that with that
transatlantic relationship will always
remain project Veritas I'm sure you know
released this video State Department
analyst kind of bragging about his
exploits working for the Democratic
socialists of America typing things
after hours and so forth but it's a
concern other videos coming out DOJ
employee
similarly part of the resistance perhaps
bragging about it does this portend more
problems of a internal resistance to
this administration are you concerned
about it and what next in this
investigation of this particular
employee so I can't speak about the
particular case but rest assured we're
aware of it and we're taking a good look
at it but step back for just a minute
here's here's my commitment president
Trump into the American people every
single person working at the United
States Department of State will be on
president Trump's mission we all have
good ideas we'll all share them we'll
give our best thoughts but at the end of
the day we have a single foreign policy
that we're executing and it's the
foreign policy the president Trump is
directing and I want every person all
across the United States government to
understand that he's our leader and we
all need to be but they shouldn't be in
this administers they're going to be
working against the administration they
should go probably find another job
don't you think absolutely if this is a
mission on which you can't sign up for
it's time to go do something else with
your time think thank you for your
service but we need to be delivering
for this president do you miss Celia I
love my time at the CI I am loving my
time here at the State Department as
well
mr. secretary thanks so much for being
so generous with your time good luck to
you